wow das universum ist ganz anders als
wir bisher gedacht haben die
untersuchungen um die es in diesem video
geht ist absolut spektakulär und hat es
in sich die konsequenzen sind gigantisch
im wahrsten sinne des wortes ich sage
nur außerirdisches leben und dunkle
materie wie was wo wie ist die lage im
kosmos jetzt sind links und science
fiction herzlich willkommen
ja ihr habt es gesehen hier hinten in
der deko hat sich schon was getan unter
den letzten wieder mehr viele
geschrieben mach mal was anders hier
fängt sein und wenn er selber ideen für
fotos habt postet mir die links unten in
den kommentaren ja ein internationales
forschungsteam wollte mal genauer wissen
wie viele sterne von welcher größe so in
einer galaxie entstehen bei uns in der
milchstraße ist der prozess ja so
ziemlich abgeschlossen bei uns entstehen
im jahr sterne mit einer gesamtmasse von
unserer sonne
das ist in kosmischen maßstäben so
ziemlich eigentlich gar nichts in der
magellanschen wolke ist das etwas anders
im dortigen sterne bildungssektor 30
dorados sind es 1000 mal mehr
sonnenmassen die dort pro jahr entstehen
und was da entsteht ist absolut
spektakulär und wirft alles um denn es
werden dort vielmehr große massereiche
sterne produziert als eigentlich bisher
angenommen wurde große massereiche
sterne sind nämlich eigentlich selten
und so war es bisher schwierig zu
bestimmen wie viel gesamtmasse sie im
all haben in der 180 tausend lichtjahre
entfernten mal gelang schon wolke ist
das eben anders in der aktiven stern
wege werden sterne am laufenden band
produziert und zwar besonders große die
forscherinnen und forscher analysierten
jetzt mit dem very large telescope der
europäischen südsternwarte eso in chile
die spektren der sterne aus denen sich
die größe ableiten lässt und sie trauten
ihren augen nicht zitat wir waren enorm
überrascht als wir feststellten dass 30
dorado so viel mehr massereiche sterne
gebildet hat als erwartet so erst autor
fabian schneider von der university of
oxford sie sind zwar immer noch seltener
als kleinere sterne also wie unsere
sonne
aber sie machen einen deutlich größeren
teil
gesamtgewicht aus weil sie so viel
schwerer sind ein beispiel ist r136a1
der blaue riese wird auf achtung 300
sonnenmassen geschätzt und leuchtet noch
mal achtung 8,7 millionen mal heller als
die sonne
ob sie bis noch vor ein paar jahren
hatte man gedacht dass bei so 150
sonnenmassen schluss ist pustekuchen
auch das war ein irrtum jetzt kommt s
und das wirft alles um zitat unsere
ergebnisse legen nahe dass der größte
anteil der gesamten stern masse nicht in
massearmen sternen steckt erklärt
mitautor chris evans vom rollator in
edinburgh die ergebnisse sind absolut
und werfen sie bedeuten dass es rund 70
prozent mehr super novell gibt als
bisher angenommen denn dazu entwickeln
sich diese sterne unter anderem das
würde bedeuten dass dreimal so viele
schwere elemente produziert würden als
bisher vermutet das sind die elemente
die zum leben nötig sind sauerstoff zum
beispiel oder eisen zitat unsere
ergebnisse haben damit weitreichende
bedeutung für unser gesamtes verständnis
des kosmos das sagt schneider und eines
finde ich absolut sensationell da viele
dieser riesensterne zu schwarzen löchern
zusammenfallen vermuten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
dass und jetzt bitte hinsetzen es
dreimal so viele schwarze löcher gibt
als bisher gedacht
ich weiß an dieser stelle nur auf die
theorie hin dass die dunkle materie auf
schwarzen löchern besteht und eben nicht
aus einer neuen art teilchen mal
überlegen wie wäre es wenn am ende
herauskommt das dunkle materie und
dunkle energie lediglich
hilfskonstruktionen waren um die
wissenslücken der kosmologie zu stopfen
ja es wäre ja nicht das erste mal in der
geschichte der menschheit es würde mich
nicht wundern wenn es solche
bahnbrechenden absolut umwerfend
erkenntnisse auch heute noch gibt es
wird auf jeden fall spannend dass die
dunkle materie aus schwarzen löchern
besteht die theorie habe ich übrigens in
diesem video vorgestellt dafür drauf
klicken wenn er sehen wollt dunkle
materie rätsel gelöst spielen schwarze
löcher eine rolle wenn ihr weiter kein
zu diesen themen verpassen wollt dann
wird mir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergessen nicht den genau auf die glocke
nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue
videos informiert ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran